people can't tolerate isolation you know
it's it's a very rare person who can who
can be on their own and stay together if
you concentrate solely on your career
you can get a long way in your career
and I would say that that's a strategy
that a minority of men preferentially do
that's all they do they work like 70 80
hours a week they go flat out on their
career they're staking everything on the
small probability of exceptional status
in a narrow domain but it's it's hard on
them they don't have a life it's very
difficult for them to have a family they
don't know how to take any Leisure
activity like they get very one
dimensional now it may be that that
unidimensionality is the price you have
to pay to be exceptional at one thing
right because if you're going to be
something like a genius level
mathematician and you want to do that
for a scientist to say it's like you're
in your lab you're in your lab all the
time you're working 70 hours a week or
80 hours a week you're smart you're
dedicated you're uni-dimensional and
that's how you get to beat all the other
people who are doing that it's the only
way but the problem is you don't get a
life now if you love being a scientist
and you have that kind of focus of Mind
well first of all you're a rare person
and second you're going to pay for it
but find more power to you often if
you're speaking about having a healthy
life that isn't what you do you spread
yourself out more so you know you have a
family you have some things that you do
outside of work that are meaningful to
you and useful you you have a network of
friends those three things a loner four
things a loner plenty to keep you well
oriented and then if one of those things
collapses you know everything doesn't go
now the price you pay for that is the
more you strive to optimize that balance
the less likely you are to be
fantastically successful at any single
one of them if you consider your life as
a whole
that might be a winning strategy one of
the things Carl Jung said I really like
this
he thought that men went after
Perfection and when women went after
wholeness there's something different at
the top of the value hierarchy so
Perfection would be
stake it all on one thing and and look
for radical success not not that all men
do that because they don't but we're
talking about extremes at least with
regards to the men that do that the
wholeness idea is more like it's like I
want one thing in my life to be 150
percent or I want five things in my life
to be 80 well there's a lot more
richness in a life where you have five
things operating at eighty percent but
you're not operating in any at any of
them at 150 percent I've met many people
who are very very rich and
you can look at their lives and they
have these huge houses and material
planting and they're shielded from many
catastrophes that would hit someone
without those resources harder but
their lives are still full of exactly
the same troubles
that characterize human life in general
and so you you compare yourself on one
dimension you don't see why the person's
worked 80 hours a week for 40 years and
it's blown all his relationships out of
the water it's like yes he's rich but
he's also old now you know he's 60 and
one of the best predictors of wealth is
age you know really do you want to be
young and poor or old and Rich it's like
I'd pick young and poor because you
can't buy youth
and and that's something that's worth
considering but you don't know what
burdens the people you're jealous of are
carrying and if you're in an
organization that only rewards the
um exercise of power the probability
that that organization is going to fail
in totality is extraordinarily High
because it's a tyrannical organization
it'll lose touch with its customers so
let's see sweet types um
they're working non-stop
corporate lawyers in New York you know
they make 700 an hour but they work all
the time all the time and there are
people who are suited for for that but
it isn't obvious that that's for
everyone or that it should be or that
it's even desirable now it's a
temperamental issue to a large degree
you know many of those people are hyper
conscientious and so if they they'll
work whatever wherever you put them what
they would do is work that's who they
are and it's biological as well you know
you think that the people who run things
are sitting at home smoking big cigars
and like telling their minions what to
do it's like that is not that's like the
1920s millionaire that's on the cover of
the Monopoly game that's no sociological
analysis I know lots of people like that
and they work all the time all the time
from the second they wake up until the
second they go to sleep and they don't
just casually work you know because I
know some of you go to the library for
six hours and you say well I study in
the library for six hours like no you
didn't you studied for half an hour
you had coffee and you looked through
Facebook and you know you went home and
you said well I studied for six hours
and you're happy about it but you know
bloody well you did hard because you
can't you know I can only read for about
three and a half hours till I'm done and
I'm pretty good at it so these people
who are running things there's corrupt
people obviously but the vast majority
of them first are self-made and second
they're so bloody efficient and smart
you cannot believe it and they work 80
hours a week and most of them happen to
be men and why is that because there are
a small number of insane men
who will do nothing but work 80 hours a
week and no matter where you put them if
you put them in the middle of a horse
with an ax all they would do is run
around dropping down trees well you want
to be an outstanding scientist it's like
okay really really that's what you want
because that means that's what you do
[Music]
because you're competing with other
people you know they're smart they're
hard working and if you want to be at
the top you have to be smarter and work
harder than any of and working hard
means working long hours I mean it also
means working diligently but if I'm
smart and hard working and I can crank
out for 70 hours a week and you do it
for 30. it's like in two years I'm so
far ahead of you you will never ever
catch up I've met lots of people who
were
was suicidal because of that but also
unwilling to take care of themselves you
know because they were so guilty about
who they were and them and their motive
being in the world that they just felt
that they weren't worth the damn trouble
there is a spark of divinity within us
and it is possible that the fact that
you have that spark of divinity with you
also means that you have the capability
to withstand that terrible vulnerability
it's an encouragement
to assume to act out the proposition
that even if life is as difficult
as it seems to be and if you're as
vulnerable and weak in a fundamental
sense as you definitely are and
characterized by this terrible
propensity for the infliction of
voluntary suffering on yourself and
others and that destructive tendency
that there's still something within you
that's so remarkable and so
aligned with
with order and being in the proper
manner that you can climb above that